hi everyone this is Jerry and this is a
live blitz game I just put a seek out
for 5 min ago for somebody 1900 or
greater there's somebody boot boot wants
to give this game ago alright so just
some development here on a g6 getting
ready to fianchetto I like to go with
this this isn't really a very ambitious
line playing the bishop here but I like
to just fish up here Queen here get some
sort of battery along this diagonal and
that here is a possibility I've seen
this before this is a very uncommon
setup especially developing this night
in front of the C pawn this C pawn
usually likes to be able to move one or
two squares forward I'm not so sure that
this is great for white pot I'm pretty
much content when I play the white
pieces to just achieve a position which
is fairly solid I've actually played
this variation quite a few times already
and I already feeling pretty good about
this position as a result of these or
this particular problem being on a white
square like if that if we were to swap
down all the pieces let's say the rooks
in the Queen's and the Knights I like my
chances better in an ending as a result
of my Miami having a good Bishop versus
his quote unquote bad bishop that's
that's a bit far-fetched but it's at
least something to be keeping in mind
just pawn to e3 getting ready to bring
out the bishop I just want pretty much
want to maintain my d4 point if it comes
under fire with c5 or 'if I've played
like a move like c3 if he takes on that
square i recapturing my pawn and then I
have play along this file will just
develop my Bishop hit my knight it's
defended his King is susceptible to
checks for as long as it remains on this
square so if the position becomes a bit
more dynamic I might be able to take
advantage of this Kings position all
right I'm just going to support D for if
he takes once again I'll take like this
and then my Queen rook will have
something constructive to do I might try
for something like a four a five let's
go for this I mean the why I should have
watched out for this right here these
rook is opposite my queen so that's
something to be careful of that for
example then I could come here I can't
take his rook takes Queen he's putting a
lot of pressure on this pawn here I'm
wondering if I should just push past is
that a good choice
should I take here
not sure what to do maybe I should get
out of this pin maybe I should bring
this rook here let's go for this he
wasn't he wasn't doing anything on f1
he's sort of doing something alright I
think my possibilities of this check
coming about her that much more likely
after after this pawn captured on this
square I'm starting to see like for
example Queen pawn takes Queen takes
would be Czech and his Queen is doing a
good job controlling this diagonal hmm
what to do
maybe I should put my queen here as well
I'm I might have to actually recapture
context I might have to recapture my
pawn my Bishop's unprotected too so now
as a result of this last move Queen here
my bishop my knight is pinned to my
bishop so that's not good I might want
to retreat my bishop so that it's at
least defended so you having unprotected
pieces makes you more susceptible to
tactics all right now he's this rook is
once again being annoying to my queen
placing an opposite my queen I'm I'm
considering just plate moving my Queen
here that's my first thought Queen here
controlling some dark squares maybe
there's thoughts of Knight here
eventually but once again I still have
to I'm in two pins right now my knight
is pinned my knight is pinned in two
directions along a diagonal and along
this file the C file Queen here
yeah it seems reasonable Bishop back
night here this might be a good spot for
the night I also have thoughts of just
pushing forward again with this AIF
trying to maybe open up the a file upon
a five pawn takes rook takes my real
have some pieces in mind pressure on the
a6 Bishop on a seven or the Bishop and
pawn what does he do is Knight really
doesn't have any good squares as a
result of this pawn being here um Queen
here making a square for the knight and
then here all right I'm going to have to
go here if not here night here
stopping night here focus on this square
and here then he might have be able to
hit the seventh rank I could be in
trouble here hmm I think my knight would
have been good on this square oh I'm
gonna I have to take and I'll go here
check is there a way I could maybe take
advantage of this Kings physician still
he's kind of low on time we have a
little bit of an audience here
let's see this night is going to be
dangerous to me night here a knight and
queen form a very powerful do well what
to do my queen is tied down to defending
a piece it's not a good position to be
in
Knight here to here getting ready to do
a smothered mate I am definitely in
rough shape I'm going to offer Queen
exchange because I feel I'm more
vulnerable my king is more vulnerable
than his so I think I would benefit from
I'm in trouble
Knight here if I take the Queen he takes
there's a fork he's going to win
material I might just have to go for and
unfortunately I might have to just go to
try and beat this guy in time because
positionally I'm crunched hmm Queen
takes Knight takes pawn b3 rook take
Knight takes rook rook takes Knight and
then I have a passed pawn my bishop is
fairly secure on c4 this is the
variation I'm going to go for I'm just
going to have to start moving quick
because I can't
this Knight is going to come here and
it's just going to be serious problems I
got to go for it Queen takes Knight
takes pawn b3 Knight takes rook rook
takes Knight I'm clearly clearly worse
off maybe I could just burn this guy's
time let's try it well to start pre
moving it's my only hope
try and burn this guy's time King here -
here
pawn here
jiwon I'll take a chance in pre-move
here and here I mean he of course could
have done something crazy and beat me
because I had pre move on there alright
let's go with this trying to open up the
a file I got a got to activate this rock
because this this rock is blockading
alright let's take care i'm worse as
soon as i come here he should go here
right now deflect my bishop from the
defense of this pawn pawn here takes
rook here I'm beat I'm way beat maybe
there's some checks over here this is a
this is a horrible position to have to
play horrible
yeah time I'm gonna have to start
thinking about sacking pieces just to
burn seconds off of his time that's the
that's the point I'm at yeah maybe he'll
go here and check pick him off rook here
ah ooh let's try this maybe he'll take
I'll take if he takes my bishop I push
and then he can't she can't stop me from
getting a queen huh
takes here I think I'm okay look back
bishop here I'm winning
I'd be winning at that point takes push
takes here you could probably go ahead
and just take the bishop Wow I'm I'm
ridiculously lucky here yeah I'm going
to actually win this game now bishop
here now he could check check and then
rook here is his only save now I think
I'll have something for that too yeah
Bishop block pawn takes pawn here now he
could swing over to the rook yeah I'm
just getting lucky he should have came
he should have come here I'm Way lucky
way lucky all right
check you might get made it check King
here check King here mate maybe just
come here any huh he were lost on time
well I got very lucky in this game I was
clearly out played here by boot raiding
1944 but rating in commenting are
appreciated thanks so much okay bye